and welcome to the latest cobia press
conference i'm
delighted to be joined this evening by
brigadier joe
fosse and by jonathan van tam
the deputy chief medical officer
across this country and around the world
this evening
people are asking themselves the same
question
about where we've got to in our fight
against covid
and that is does the progress towards a
vaccine that's been announced today mean
that we are at the beginning of the end
of our troubles so
let me set out our assessment
the pfizer bioentec vaccine has been
tested on over 40
000 volunteers and interim results
suggest
it is proving 90 effective at protecting
people
against the virus but we haven't
yet seen the full safety data and these
findings
also need to be peer reviewed so
we've cleared one significant hurdle but
there are several more to go
before we know the vaccine can be used
what i can say is that if and when
this vaccine is approved we in this
country will be ready to start using it
earlier this year the uk government
ordered 40 million
doses of the pfizer vaccine enough for
about a third of the population
since you need two doses each and that
puts us towards the front of the
international pack on a per capita
basis and i should add that we've
ordered over 300 million doses
from five other vaccine candidates
as well if the fisa vaccine passes all
the rigorous safety checks
and is proved to be effective then we
will begin
a uk-wide nhs led program
of vaccine distribution we will decide
the order in which people are offered
the vaccine vaccination
taking account of recommendations from a
group of scientific experts
the joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
and they're looking at a range of
factors including the different
characteristics
of different types of vaccines to work
out the most effective way
to protect as many people as possible
and save as many lives
as we can we'll be sending out more
detail about that
in due course but and you know
i'm going to say this i must stress that
these are very
very early days we've talked for a long
time
or i have about the distant bugle of the
scientific cavalry
uh coming over the brow of the hill i
can tell you
that tonight that toot of that bugle
is louder but it's still some
way off we absolutely cannot
rely on this news as a solution
and the biggest mistake we could make
now
would be to slacken our resolve
at a critical moment because on friday
sage reported that the r is above one in
england
uh though that doesn't take account of
the current uh national restrictions
alas the death figures are rising
running at an average of 300 a day sadly
double
uh where they were 24 days ago the
number of coveted patients in hospital
has risen to from just over 10
000 two weeks ago to nearly 13 000
on the 5th of november and we're heading
towards the levels of the of the
previous peak
irrespective of whether there is a
vaccine on the way
or not we must continue to do everything
possible
right now to bring the are done and
that's why
we hope and believe that mass
testing will help and our first pilot
began in liverpool on friday in
partnership
with liverpool city council we've tested
thousands of people there but there's
still a lot
more to do so please if you are in
liverpool get yourself along
to a testing center there are 19 at the
moment with more
still to come and the more people get
tested
the better we can protect that great
city and drive
uh the disease done in liverpool so do
it for your friends
for your relatives for your community
and
i want to thank the fantastic support of
the armed the army
of the people of liverpool and liverpool
city council and we're now
going further by sending out hundreds
of thousands of rapid lateral flow tests
to local authorities right across
england and also of course
to the devolved administrations we're
working
with universities to establish as soon
as possible
similar mass testing capacity for
students
up and down the country but while we're
making progress
this project is still in its infancy
and neither mass testing nor progress
on vaccines so they're both vital
uh arrows in our epidemiological quiver
they're both
uh part of the uh key parts of
of our fight against uh kobet uh at the
present time
they are no substitute for the national
restrictions
uh the social distancing hand hygiene
and all the rest so now
it's more important than ever to follow
the rules
i know it's been a tough first weekend
of these autumn restrictions and i'm
especially grateful to the royal
british legion and all those who worked
so hard
to ensure that no virus would stop us
yesterday
from honoring the memory of those who
gave their lives
for our freedom but we must get through
this
to the second of december when these
measures expire
and we plan to move forward with a a
tiered
approach remember the basics then hands
face
space and follow the rules and that's
how together we can protect
the nhs save lives and get the virus
back in its box
that is what we will do thank you i'm
now going to
hand to uh brigadier fosse who's going
to
uh talk about the unrivalled logistical
expertise
of the british army that's helping to
deliver mass testing
uh to liverpool over to you brigadier
thank you prime minister and good
evening everyone as the prime minister
said
i am brigadier joe fosse and i'm
coordinating the military support
to mass testing in liverpool it is a
privilege to be invited
to help the great city of liverpool in
its hour of need
we're really pleased to be in the city
and relish the opportunity
to bring our unique planning skills
ability to respond quickly
and logistics know-how to increase the
city's
own testing capacity over 2
000 troops have answered the call to
help liverpool tackle covet 19
by setting up a number of testing sites
in the city
to date we have established 19 sites
and we are working hard with the
authorities to deliver more each day
i should point out that we are working
in support
of liverpool city council the nhs
clinical commissioning group
and the department for health and social
care to prove the concept
of rapid testing we are demonstrating
partnership in action and are together
in enhancing the city's ability to break
the chains of transmission
and helping to drive down the number of
covered cases
i want to take a moment to explain to
viewers what it is that the military
is doing
this is a lateral flow test
and these are the tests that we are
using liverpool they are
very simple to use you will all know
what a swab looks like
you will be in an enclosed booth
all covered controls will be in place
you put the swab
in your mouth and then in your nose
and give it back to the soldier who will
complete the test
the new piece of equipment is this two
inch
bit of plastic it is this lateral flow
device
that produces such a speedy result
i have taken one this morning to make
sure i was covered free
the test returns results within the hour
without the need for it to be sent to a
lab
you will receive a message by email or
text with your result
these lateral flow tests offer the
chance for more regular
and rapid testing
many of us have served on operations
abroad
we know what makes an effective team the
council
the nhs the emergency services and most
importantly the people of liverpool have
worked together
to make an outstanding coalition it is a
privilege to work alongside them
we're extremely grateful for such a warm
response more so because so many
soldiers come from the city region
and are excited to be giving something
back to their communities
for example lance corporal lee johnson
of the royal electrical and mechanical
engineers
has been out helping his community in
anfield where today we set up a testing
center
in the football stadium using his sign
language skills
trooper jordan turner of the king's
royal hussars
managed to translate the testing process
for a deaf
member of the community and sapper david
mckenzie
of the royal engineers has gone from
building hospitals
for the united nations in south sudan to
delivering test sites
to safeguard the residents of liverpool
so our message to the people of
liverpool is clear
we are set up and ready for you to come
and get tested
please do not hesitate
make the most of this opportunity
what we are trying now is a possible
route out of lockdown
and a way to get on with our lives
the armed forces have always answered
the call in terms of crisis
covid19 poses many challenges and
affects us all in many ways
but we in the military stand ready to
serve our communities
thank you thank you very much brigadier
i'm not going to go to
jonathan van tam just to say a little
bit more about uh the vaccine from the
from a scientific and medical point of
view thank you prime minister
good evening you will all have seen the
news today the announcement by pfizer
biontech
and i have to say that this is
really a very important scientific
breakthrough
i'm certain of that i want to first of
all
begin to thank people around the world
including here in the uk
who have been clinical trials volunteers
we would not be talking to you about the
news today
if there weren't volunteers who go into
clinical trials
to help us find cures and vaccines
against this awful disease
and thank you also to the hundreds of
thousands of
unsung scientists in the vaccine
industry who've worked around the clock
and are still
working around the clock trying to find
yet further vaccines for the world
this is truly appreciated so today's
news is the first
vaccine and the first step and it is
very exciting but i want to explain to
you
a little bit more about what the next
steps are
and why right now the messages stand
fast
rather than get too over excited
about quite where we are so we've seen
today the results that show the
effectiveness
of the first vaccine we haven't seen
the detail of those but we've seen the
headline results
the next step is to see the safety data
and i imagine that that will come in the
next few days
there have been 44 000 volunteers
in the major trial being reported today
so 22 000 have had the vaccine that's a
lot of safety data
and we have to see that and understand
it
safety is every bit in fact i would say
it's more
important than vaccine effectiveness
and the arbiters of safety and
effectiveness in this country
are our mhra our regulatory body
and they are truly world-class and they
are robustly independent
and so it's for them in time to form
their own judgment answer about this
and future vaccines they are the only
people involved in that
then if we can get to a point where
vaccines are beginning to be authorized
for use in the uk
the next question is well who are we
going to give them to
and here again an independent body the
jcvi the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization
will guide the government on the
priorities
and you will have seen on the jcvi
website that they have already
identified
a preliminary priority list
it is preliminary because until that
committee can see the full
characteristics of each vaccine that
list cannot be finalized and it has to
take into account
when vaccines are likely to arrive and
what kind of conditions they need
for deployment because they all have
different
storage and delivery requirements so
that is work for the future
but what is already very clear from the
jcvi
uh work to date is that by
far and away age is the biggest priority
for patients who most need the vaccines
and need to get those vaccines first if
they are safe and effective
and so you can expect that the theme of
increasing age being the highest
priority to be a theme that
stays with us as we go on this journey
i'm hopeful because of all that but not
yet
certain that we could begin to see some
vaccine
by christmas what i want to do now is
talk about the slightly broader context
of all of this
so the current vaccine that's being
announced its results are announced
today
targets the s protein of the coronavirus
and um so far all we knew was that
vaccines could
give us antibodies against the s protein
we did not know
if vaccines would prevent disease and so
this is a huge
milestone but more importantly
it is good news for many other vaccines
to come
because almost all of the vaccines
coming also target
the s protein so this is like um
you know getting to the end of a playoff
final it's gone to penalties
the first player goes up scores the goal
you haven't won the cup yet but what it
does
is it tells you that the goalkeeper can
be beaten
and that's where we are today that first
sign
so what do we know about the vaccine
well we know
this particular vaccine prevents disease
that's clear from the effectiveness
readout that we've had
today what we don't know yet
and where you have to be patient and
stick with us
is that we don't know what this means
yet
for when we can get life back to normal
when we can start to lift some of the
restrictions that we live under
frankly we're in the middle of the
second wave
and i don't see the vaccine making any
difference
for the wave we are now in i'm hopeful
that it may prevent future waves but
this one we have to battle through to
the end without
vaccine we have to keep pressing
hard for now we've seen a swallow but
this is
very much not the summer please don't
relax
much depends on the extent to which you
continue
to follow the rules not only through the
current lockdown period but afterwards
when we hope to return to a time of
slightly lower restrictions it would be
a
colossal mistake on the part of any one
of us
to relax at this point but
vaccine supplies we hope will
come subject always subject
to authorization by the mhra
and if they do when they do we
might be able to look towards the end of
spring
for a much better horizon than we have
in front of us right now
we will know more in time please stick
with us for now
thank you prime minister thank you very
much john let's go to questions from the
public and the media starting with abide
from
from glasgow how will university
students get back home for christmas
safely to their family if permitted and
is it safe to do so
and how will they return safely back on
campus in january
well uh abe thank you i think i'll uh
answer that
obviously i'm very grateful to
university students for
the way they've been able to get the uh
the disease
down in the on the campuses where
they've been recently it's been a
fantastic effort by by universities
clearly
we don't want uh young people going back
and
uh infecting elderly members of their
family over the
over the christmas period so to tomorrow
or very shortly abed will be
uh issuing a guidance for uh what they
should do i know that terms will start
to end from about uh
the 30th of november onwards and we'll
we'll be sure to be giving
guidance for exactly what university
students
should be doing as they plan uh their
return home
how to make sure that they that you
university students do
uh as much as you can to to protect your
elderly relatives
anything you want to add on that
jonathan
thank you prime minister no i i think
i'd just say that um
i know colleagues are working on a
solution for how to get
students home as safely as possible it
is a
genuinely important question to ask
and uh i don't think i should uh comment
until the guidance is is issued
okay that guidance will be coming up uh
very soon thank you let's go to claire
from coventry claire
uh how how are you going to uh address
adequately the mental health crisis
that has resulted from a a year of of
covered
uh restrictions and again i'll ask uh
jonathan to
to comment on on the mental health
crisis
there's no doubt that uh the
this pandemic has had a big impact on uh
people's uh mental health i was talking
to representatives of the
uh of the samaritans uh this morning in
my own
uh constituency in in in in oxbridge and
you know it's the the loneliness i think
the the sense of
uh not being able to to see other people
that's been uh
caused by some of the lockdown measures
alas
all sorts of uh anxieties that people
are prone to and they have been prone to
what we're doing claire is we're
investing massively
in mental health uh a 13 billion pound
investment in
supporting nhs mental health but also
supporting the the mental health
charities
uh that uh do such have been doing uh
such a great job
uh throughout this crisis but obviously
the best thing we can do
is uh bring the crisis to an end as
fast as we can follow the guidance uh
get through the current period
uh on december the second and and then
allow things
uh to to to get better as i'm sure i'm
sure they will
uh jbt thank you prime minister
there is an enormous mental health
burden and even if not a formal mental
health
issue a feel really rubbish
um about where we are now feeling
that's across the country because our
lives have changed
we can't do the things that we normally
do as human beings we can't
interact in the way that we want to
we don't have the nice things like sport
on a saturday afternoon as a stadium and
so forth
and it is really tough from that
perspective
um one of the things that
we can do to try and make this
these restrictions as short as possible
is to follow them to the letter and that
means everybody
if we do that the likelihood of the
restrictions working
driving the r below one and actually
shrinking the size of the epidemic
um for the first time in months is
realistic
and that's the most important thing i
think to get out of
feeling the way we feel and we do feel
that way
thanks very much uh claire let's go to
fergus walsh of
the bbc thank you very much prime
minister
um question for jonathan van tam how
many people
in the uk will need to be immunized with
an effective vaccine before
life can start returning to normal
and to the prime minister how
potentially important
are the vaccine results today
yes so thanks for the question fergus
the answer to your question is that
it is kind of yes and no in one sense
we don't know because the one thing we
know about these vaccines at the moment
is that they will prevent illness
due to sars cov2 due to the covid19
virus
as diagnosed by pcr that's all we know
we do not know yet if these vaccines
will prevent asymptomatic infection
and therefore we do not know if these
vaccines
will prevent virus shedding and
therefore have an
effect on community transmission
that is something it is not possible to
know at this point in time
when we understand more about whether
these vaccines simply modify disease
or whether they also reduce transmission
then i think we can give you
a more sensible estimate of that but
that's the don't know part of the
question the
very certain part of the question
is that we know that um
the vast majority of the burden
of hospitalization and death
is being driven by the elderly
and the hospitalization rates rise very
dramatically
after the age of 50.
and knowing that
gives us hope that if we can deploy
in due course when authorized a safe and
effective vaccine
in the elderly populations we should
i'm hopeful it'll the proof will be in
the pudding
but i'm hopeful that we will actually
see a very dramatic
decline in the burden in hospitals
but that can't happen all at once
we don't have the vaccine supplies yet
they are not authorized yet they will
not all come
in one go and when they do even with
enormous planning from the nhs it is
going to take
time to roll that kind of program out
but it does explain why the published
jcvi advice
begins with the top priority group
older adults resident in care homes and
care home workers
next all those aged 80 years of over
and health and social care workers next
all those 75 years and over
following on 70 65 it's on the jcvi
website i won't take up time
i'm sure you've seen it anyway but that
explains
why we are planning when we have
authorized vaccines
to start in this way if we possibly can
thank you uh thanks uh jonathan ferguson
well i've talked about the three
scientific
uh tools that i think are going to be
most useful in
uh defeating this as far as the the the
weapons that we have at our
disposal i've i've talked a lot in the
last few weeks
about uh better therapies better
medicine dexamethasone
other treatments that are reducing the
mortality rates in in hospital
uh we we've got the brigadier here to
talk about
uh the the mass testing that we're
rolling out which i think is full of
potential
for our ability to uh defeat the the
virus
um but when it's come to the vaccine the
third uh
part of the third pillar of the tripod
as it were i've always been quite
cautious
because uh you know it's it's a long
time since sars broke out and we still
don't have
an effective vaccine against sar so i've
been very very hesitant to
to get people's hopes up fergus
unnecessarily
uh so i'm listening very carefully to
what uh jonathan and others are saying
about
the potential of this news it's
obviously
potentially uh very very good news but
there are still
a lot of hurdles that need to be
overcome
before we can uh be certain about
the efficacy of this uh of this vaccine
exactly how it is going to uh to work
what i can tell you obviously
is that uh we've secured uh
a large proportion of the uh of the
supply that
uh pfizer will be uh will be making
uh in addition to the uh the 300
uh million other doses of other types of
vaccine that we've we've also uh
secured uh if they come good and i think
one of the one of the interesting things
that
the most fascinating thing that jonathan
uh uh
has said uh to my mind this this evening
is that this this vaccine uh offers
a ray of hope for all those other uh
vaccines if it really works because it
targets the s protein of
of coronavirus it doesn't just create
antibodies and
that seems to me to be very very
interesting but it is crucial that we do
not
overdo it we cannot let our enthusiasm
uh tonight uh run away with us folks i'm
very very sorry
uh to say this it's more vital uh than
ever now
that we follow the the basics uh that we
wait and see whether this
uh vaccine lives up to uh its promise
uh we continue with the measures we have
in place until
december the second when they will uh
expire and we continue with the
with the basic guidance as as jonathan
says
uh let's go to tom clark of itv
uh thank you prime minister um going
back to the vaccine again
um one of the hurdles of course is
ensuring we get a supply that you you
rightly mentioned we've ordered
i think 40 million doses of this fisa
vaccine for the uk
how confident are you given the global
excitement about this
vaccine announcement today that you can
fulfill those contracts that they'll
actually be
delivered upon and um a second thought
one of the government's leading advisors
on
on the science of cope with today
something very enthusiastic things could
return to normal as early as
next spring you don't seem to share that
enthusiasm
have you been burned perhaps by your
experience working with scientists
in the area of testing for example uh
well
uh tom i think on your on your first
point about
uh the the security of the supply i i'm
very hopeful that
uh we'll get as i say the the ones that
we've
we've ordered that that's what we've
done and i think the
the vaccine task force for uh
their initiative they went they've been
out uh securing supplies for the uk for
for a long time now and it's right that
they've been doing that just on a
speculative
basis and look i mean yes of course i
remain you know
violently optimistic about the prospects
of this country next year
uh i i just don't want to um
let people run away with the idea that
this
uh development today is necessarily
uh a home run a slam dunk uh a shot to
the back of the net
yet uh i think that's that's how
uh i feel about it i think we've got a
way to go
uh tom uh is it good news of course it's
good news
but uh there's a there's a long way a
long way i'm afraid before
we've got this thing beat
thanks tom making vaccines is really
difficult
and um many things can go wrong during
manufacture and indeed each
batch has to be quality assured before
it can be released
it's not a case of you get the
authorization from the regulator
and then hey ho you can just start
making it no no no
every single batch has to be quality
assured and released
and things can and do and have always
gone wrong in
that quality assurance process for
perfectly good reasons
and for that reason um you know i think
we have to
be optimistic but we have to
wait and see how vaccine manufacture
goes not only for this company but for
many others
this to me is like a train journey where
you're standing on the station it's wet
it's windy it's horrible
and two miles down the tracks two lights
appear and it's the train
and it's a long way off we're at that
point at the moment that's the efficacy
result
then we hope the train slows down safely
to get into the station that's the
safety data
and then the train stops and at that
point the doors don't open
the guard has to make sure it's safe to
open the doors
that's the mhra that's the regulator
and when the doors open i hope there's
not a
an unholy scramble for the seats
the jcvi has very clearly said
which people are going to need the seats
most
and they are the ones who should get on
the train first that's how we have to
frame this
and right now it's a couple of miles
down the tracks
and we've just seen the lights come
round the bend
thanks thanks very very much um tom
uh let's go to victoria macdonald
channel four
thank you prime minister um you read out
the list
um professor bantam on
the priorities you said they were
preliminary but given the prime
minister's determination
to keep schools and universities open
is it not a glaring
missing from that list should there be
teachers on that list and also can you
tell me prime minister would the cabinet
get a priority for being vaccinated and
can i also
ask given that you started prime
minister uh
talking about the death figures and the
r number
where on a scale of 1 to 10 are you and
your confidence
that you will be able to lift the
england's lockdown
on december the 2nd well uh
brilliant beautiful thank you thanks
thanks uh very much
um uh victoria on on your your first
question about you know who
who gets it which which categories of of
people um
we will be guided very much by the joint
committee on vaccination and
vaccination immunization uh
i think you you've got to look at where
the
doses can be most appropriately uh
distributed to
uh protect people to save life and to
drive down the r and that that
and uh everything flows from uh from
that and
uh that's why i thought that uh what uh
john and that say was was absolutely
absolutely right uh and on
december the second and uh and
don't forget this package expires
on uh december the second uh at the
moment
uh if you ask me for my estimate of how
we're doing as a country well i think
that actually people are
really pulling together and though the r
is above one and the
although the uh i'm afraid infection
rates are uh
are increasing uh prevalence is rising
certainly
across the entire uh country and uh
hospitalizations uh
uh are continuing to to increase uh
i do believe uh that this package of
measures
uh in combination with the uh the
previous uh
efforts uh will get the r below one i
bought i've got i've got a lot of
confidence but it depends on all of us
doing it together and observing it
and not being mentally sidetracked by uh
the sudden surge of optimism about
a vaccine and yes it's it's it's good
news but let's focus on
uh on what we're doing until december
the second
thank you very much let's go to jason
groves of the daily mail
jason thanks prime minister um survey
suggests uh
uh something like a quarter of people
wouldn't take a vaccine if they were
offered one
how concerned are you about uh
misinformation by the sort of
uh anti-vats lobby you mentioned
liverpool uh is the testing there
uh the take up as high as you would like
and can i ask you quickly on the u.s
election
um i don't know whether you've heard uh
from
joe biden yet but obviously you were
offended president trump
would you now advise him to throw in the
towel and
will you miss him when he's gone from
the international stage um
uh well um jason first of all i think
the
um the uh andy bach's argument holds no
water i think uh
people need to uh remember that in
in having a vaccination you're not just
protecting yourself uh you're protecting
anybody who
uh could get infected by you uh or your
family as a vector of the
of the disease so i hope very much that
people won't uh
won't be listening to those uh those
types of of arguments
on on the the us elections
well i just want to repeat what i've
i've said before that i i really
congratulate
uh president-elect biden and uh and
kamala harrison who's i think
going to be the first i know the first
ever uh
female vice president of the united
states and uh yes
uh this country's had a good
relationship with the
uh with the white house over the last
few years but it's had a good
relationship with the white house for
many many
uh years and i have no doubt that we
will continue to
have a very very strong very close
relationship with our american friends
and one thing
that is very exciting uh that you're
already seeing
from the incoming administration is
their
their willingness to join uh the uk in
uh the the campaign to tackle climate
change
and as you know we're chairing the uh
the the cops were hosting i should say
the cop 27
cop 26 uh summit in uh in
in glasgow uh next year and
the uk has been leading in in calling
the first major economy uh to call for
countries to get to to net zero carbon
emissions by
2050 and uh suddenly with the with the
advent of
uh of president-elect biden uh we're
seeing the us
uh really willing to take a lead to on
on climate change which you know
uh i i think is is great news to say
nothing of of nato and
uh and all sorts of things i think you
had there was another question buried in
there jason which i've
i've i've neglected have i answered all
your questions
well not quite uh just on president
trump is it you've congratulated a
successor is it time for him to
throw in the title i see oh yeah right
right quickly about liverpool as well uh
is it yes sorry you did that through
yeah yeah
sorry thank you thank you uh look on on
um
i don't wish to offer any other
commentary on uh
the us uh election
our friends in america have their
presence is not for me to uh offer
uh commentary on it uh that i you know
clearly uh
clearly uh uh want to congratulate uh
president biden
what i would say about liverpool is that
um
yes it's absolutely true that uh we want
to see more
but don't forget that we're we're
massively increasing the number of
testing centers over the course of the
next
few days i think i think i'll hand over
to the to the brigadier
on this and uh we're hopeful that more
people will take it up but perhaps i
could
uh go to jonathan first and into the
brigadier
yes i just wanted to come back in jason
on your point about vaccine
misinformation
vaccine misinformation has been out
there ever since the first vaccines were
made
and it is exactly that misinformation
and i don't propose we give it any
further air time
but your statistic actually tells me
that 75 percent
of people are keen to get a covid 19
vaccine
and if you look at the staggering
likelihood
of hospitalization or death with
increasing age
and in the elderly i predict very
strongly
that there will be a very significant
demand
in the elderly in particular for this
vaccine
and ones that follow thanks uh
anything to say about about liverpool um
jason i think it's important to
recognize that this is the fourth day
of a pilot program of a mass testing
approach that may be the first in the
western hemisphere
we've already had a number of thousands
of residents of liverpool city
respond to the call and we anticipate
that growing significantly as the
message
begins to uh begins to radiate so i
think we will start to see
much more uptake from a community
that is driving forward as an incredibly
cohesive team
with very very strong community
responses so that
take up that footfall we anticipate to
rise
very quickly this week thanks very much
let's go to
kate ferguson of the sun
thank you prime minister a question for
professor john van tan
first um you said you hope britain could
be heading back to normality by next
spring
what does normal mean so will brits be
able to bend their face masks
hug their grannies kiss their dates
again
and for the pm i know you're working on
a plan to rescue christmas with the
devolved assemblies
how confident are you that brits will be
able to travel around the uk for their
christmas dinners this year
and will brits be able to hug their
grannies on christmas day
thanks kate um look i'd love to give you
a really simple answer to this
and say oh yes all the things you asked
for
in what i suppose is an early christmas
list from you
you'll be able to do by easter i can't
give you that assurance at the moment
what i can tell you is that with time
and subject to authorization
by the regulator once these vaccines
begin to be deployed then over a period
of time
they will make a significant difference
to the kind of disease levels we see in
the uk
at the moment whether
they will reduce transmission as i said
earlier
in in the briefing is something we do
not know yet
and that is a crucial factor that will
understand
how far vaccines take us
towards the kind of future that you
um aspire to as i aspire to we'd love it
wouldn't we
but right now the key message is
we're working on that we're very aware
of what is needed
but your job whilst we do that work is
to hold this
r below zero below one
for as long as up for as long as you can
and um to work to follow the measures
so that we can get into that space in
the first instance
uh and okay just the simplest thing i
can
i can do is just repeat what i've said
uh
before the more we comply the the more
scrupulously uh we we follow the the
guidance and
the rules uh right now uh the better all
of our chances of having
a christmas that's as as close to normal
as possible that's the
that's that's the objective that we're
uh we're working for
let's go lastly to joe murphy of the
evening standard
joe thank you prime minister um
professor vantam can i ask you to share
a bit more of
what you know about the likely time it
would take from a first injection of
this vaccine
to actually being immunised for example
if people were had their first
administration on december the first
is it likely or unlikely that they might
be able to
hug people on christmas day um
and prime minister if we just looking at
your old stamping ground of london
business leaders
are saying the vacci the sorry the
covid rate is going down in london
and it's much lower already than other
major cities
they're asking you would you consider if
it's safe
and if the numbers keep falling whether
you'd let london
out of lockdown before december the 2nd
and if not could you at least say that
you're willing to put london
into tier one again so that more things
and businesses stay open
yeah thank you so um it's a very good
question joe and
i'm really glad you kind of reminded me
of it to be truthful
um all but one of the vaccines that are
the likely
big name contenders um over the next
12 months or so have a vaccine that
requires
two doses to give protection
and the interval between the two doses
varies between 21 and 28
days apart now on
basic immunological principles we would
expect
the response to a vaccine
to be maximal no no more than before the
14 until at 14 days has elapsed
after the dose so um
yes there'll be some partial protection
after a first dose one would think
but the safe space is have two doses
wait at least 14 days and at that point
you can be assured that to the extent
that your body is going to
work with the vaccine to produce
antibodies to protect you
that is when you're going to get into
the period when you are
protected so i'm afraid i'm saying
to be sure 14 days after the second dose
and joe on on london and other areas
where
uh we're seeing you know the the the
gradient being
killed down or the disease not rising as
fast as
uh as it as it has been uh you know this
is no accident
this is because of the heroic collective
efforts and sacrifice
the people of london elsewhere the
northeast it's uh it's flattening
uh that is that is because people are
following the guidance
making a huge effort to uh to just
to distance themselves and all the other
things that we
we know and uh yet i you know it is
still true that
overall the virus is still doubling in
this country and i
i saw the data this morning uh alas it's
it's doubling in some places
faster than uh than elsewhere uh
about one in ninety people uh now have
the
the virus one in one in 90. uh that's a
that's a lot of
a lot of people alas and we're gonna see
uh those cases
uh sadly feeding through uh into our
hospitals as as they are
as they are now uh but you know
what the point that you make does show
that human agency collective action all
of us
pulling together really can work and
what we've got to do
now in the run-up to uh to christmas
right up to december the second
is to make sure that we do follow this
guide and so as i say
we can all have as normal a christmas as
possible
thank you all very much thank you thank
you
you